there is a price that you're paying
which is you're 16 and you're living out
your life in front of everybody and I
got to imagine there's some times where
you lose some privacy and you feel like
that's that's too bad
and you'll mention something in an
article you'll talk about your favorite
candy yeah what happened here it was
well I had talked about my favorite
candy and then so many girls they
brought me which it was sour patch kids
and everybody brought me sour patch kids
right oh and I got so sick of them and
they started throwing them at you in
concert and you're getting pelted you
just wanted to mention you liked sour
patch kids next thing you know they're
being exactly so I have a new favorite
candy and you have a new favorite candy
well you ain't a tell people what that
is well I don't really like wanna
because it come on we're on pretty late
it's not a big deal you can tell us
what's your new favorite kind of candy
is you promise you won't tell I won't
tell anybody
yes we won't tell anybody none of us
know you know those marshmallow peeps
oops you're fantastic you're gonna have
a break
[Applause]
are you sure about that yeah do you have
a third favorite kind of thing
Never Say Never is in theaters I'm
really glad it wasn't something like
Fudd I know canned hams we'd all be in a
lot it's none of those ago really from
God
yes from God yes
really really nice we'll get you some
new clothes really nice talking to you
thanks so much
[Applause]
you